à quelques semaines des vacances de
février le renouveau du ski ici il faut
le savoir à côté du skieur du dimanche
comme vous et moi la mode de la
fantaisie et du freestyle comme on dit
en anglais ne touche plus seulement les
surfeurs le champion de cette discipline
à ce qui est français il s'appelle
candide thovex il saute par dessus les
routes par dessus les toits des maisons
c'est un savoyard de 22 ans et son style
a fait école julien benedetto floride
aux comptes
il a fait de la montagne sont éternels
terrain de jeu on a du mal à l'imaginer
mais dans le grand cirque blanc
ce petit acrobat est presque une légende
vivante candide thovex 22 ans est le roi
incontesté du freestyle traduction
faites ce que vous voulez avec moscou
le ski s'essouffler depuis l'avènement
du snowboard et puis quand 17 ans voler
la révolution
en deux temps trois mouvements
il ya toujours des choses avancer
vraiment pas de monotonie penser c'est
vraiment vraiment grand plaisir candide
thovex a vite quitté les bancs de
l'école pour les télésièges un idole
edgar grospiron un exploit devenir le
premier français à remporter les x games
équivalent djo pour les sports extrêmes
mais la compétition et ses juges ne
l'intéressent plus ce qu'ils aiment
qu'en dis tu t'es fixé lui-même les
règles du jeu on veut vraiment garder
cette liberté ne pas être trop encadré
que ça reste vraiment un plaisir que n'a
pas d'entraînement par jusqu'hier on se
fait plaisir
candide thovex à transformer une
pratique d'ado déjanté en business de
professionnels reconnus par les siens il
réalise ses propres films candu à 30000
exemplaires par an toutes les grandes
marques de sport d'hiver s'arrachent le
phénomène son dernier sponsor lui a
offert un contrat de 200 millions
un candide thovex lui
il va nous permettre de vendre plus de
ski du moins c'est ce qu'on espère c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a pris 3,6 2,5 à des
choses comme ça hein
voilà l'effet thovex un style et un
langage adoptés par les jeunes skieurs
qui ont envahi les snow park pour imiter
qu'en disait à la section freestyle de
la clusaz on a même dû refuser une
centaine d'inscriptions car tous rêvent
de rejoindre l'aérien candide thovex là
hop
quelque part entre ciel et neige